it's brilliant I mean it's incredible to
actually seize the capsule that you know
you flew to space and come back and see
it here on splendor science museum it
brings back so many powerful memories
and obviously you have a huge attachment
for something that has kept your life
and seen you through such rigors going
to place banks a wonderful city in the
morning sitting in the story is actually
is quite comfortable once you get in
there it's a very tight space is very
cramped space it wouldn't suit anybody
through suffer support from
claustrophobia but it was once you get
in there and settled into your seat it
can be quite comfortable
the first view out of the right-hand
window there is on morning there was a
nose fairing go that your first
opportunity to look out the window
relaunch is about five o'clock in the
evening from Kazakhstan heading east so
we went straight into the nighttime part
of Earth's orbit
so my first view was just being near by
night and seeing a wonderful moon right
through this window behind me
reentry is actually much more dynamic
than more launches is a wild ride is
great sign it so it's constant
acceleration getting up to Mach 25
reentry is is I mean almost violent in
the fact that you're experiencing
walking when the parachute opens here
it's very large canopy it can't open
straight the way you're still going
above the speed of sound when you come
back to the lower part of the atmosphere
we have to have a briefing to come out
first then a drogue chute is like three
drogue chutes before this main canopy
opens and the whole process of slowing
you down
and those drogue chutes deploying is
very violent then finally the main
canopy opens never being settled sounds
being back on earth with one school and
you know we're hitting the steppes of
Kazakhstan is a hard landing we have
soft landing struts on this vehicle the
kind of cushion of low a little bit but
it's great to get back to you as well
cause of Kazakhstan the fresh air and
the fresh grass really great experience
[Music]